[Music]
and a commodity levitation is submitted
by David's wife in Korea oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
Merrill now I know who the [ __ ] is a
quiet researchers are now using sound to
levitate objects and is changing the
medical industry industry industry don't
tell me this [ __ ] because I saw how
fake this stuff was perfect there's like
a guru that basically like levitates and
then they hold this like cane like that
and then they're in the air and then
they just have like a hat there you put
money in but the whole trick is the
whole thing it goes up like this and it
goes to their legs the street so
levitation is alive not that much this
is a completely different algae this is
at the pier is the hospital bro alright
so I'm going to show you guys this video
well they will explain this acoustic
levitation technology yeah that's
[ __ ] nuts
[Music]
that is awesome
real good photography
we take medicines for drugs imagined a
from cacao hallelujah by each month we
told you Tecna is a Superfund contractor
naturally
[Music]
that is crazy yeah wolf well what are
you trying to do how does that happen do
you know the science behind it I know
that they're using two speakers to emit
22 kilohertz frequencies at each other
which is enough to levitate whatever
drop with a pair of testing right now
but what is that it creates like some
sort of sound wave and it creates some
space or like what does that sound have
to do it anything I guess what they're
saying is that they can mix the
compounds that they're working with like
it can even be gases and then they can
even have a more controlled environment
for what the experiments that they
trying to create in the actual
levitation of it but what they're trying
to to get it to a certain point is to
get to be able to master the technology
in a way where they can distribute
medicine to specific targeted areas so
they don't so like what he said in the
video how like you take a medication
I'll just spread throughout your whole
body but you can use this down
levitation to like somehow I don't know
exactly how but somehow make that
medicine goes to that targeted area only
also if you take ecstasy and you want it
to only be in your brain and you don't
want it to harm your liver and
everything else then just like just put
holes in my brain and nowhere else
this can be really effective in space
because when when they're in space and
like they're trying to do experiments in
space like with liquid and things like
without gravity they just float around
right but then using the cells now they
could control where the pee is going
because before they pee is just
splashing everywhere but now they can
pee and have the two speakers move the
pee into the trashcan or in the toilet
would be great and I you know what
problem I have at home like would you go
pee in a bathtub you're the only person
that has choices
yeah go brother go what do I say or the
backyard even ask my plan he's like hey
do you think it'd be okay if I just pee
in this bottle I'm like what why just go
to the fungi after that when you were
measuring your PIN I remember that the
second time unfortunately was we were
about to have a meeting we were at
barbell gym and then you are like hey do
you think I could pee in this bottle mi
tink we should go to [ __ ] back oh
yeah why did you write in a bottle no
because we're supposed to have a meeting
we're running out of time that makes
sense and it's all long as P takes top
you have to walk to the bathroom or I
can go to the [ __ ] gym you guys know
it I love it
let's say me and Amy need to have a
meeting right I don't need my bladder in
the meeting so we can have a meeting and
I suggest peace lovely interesting okay
that's okay
I think Jenny would wait as the
Australian say no not nice okay I like
that way of no better try nowadays okay
how about stop stop
I like stop it stop it Lana in Vegas the
other Aziz came I'm a big hip things
don't mean it like you're really
interesting right anyway I think they
fell on their heads off nice a week
early from another state no that's
forgotten somewhere like up some brie
also noted scum brie o mean says a lot
right I like the way Australian people
disc people to scum Bri that heard me
know when she gets in she says get [ __ ]
I'm like ooh sandbags you guys don't
stay right here I'm like no get [ __ ] oh
oh we have a similar thing though [ __ ]
yourself
no like when you [ __ ] about your house
[ __ ] me a lot of my [ __ ] me today [ __ ]
me but I get start saying stuff like
that and then I get into places where I
never thought I'd ever go so be like god
dammit [ __ ] me off the art with 10-6 I'm
like mmm
do I really actually want that 10 sticks
tench big that's yeah I do that's what
I'm really angry they don't even sell
them in bundles is 10 do they
oh where do you find tips to go to Home
Depot figure out if it sells them and a
half-dozen yes hi two of them and get
rid of two and then I attend one yeah
then you stick them in yourself I mean I
think I'm asking someone else to do it
pull me
oh you're needy though I just know that
where you're from there's some crazy
spiders and I don't trust that [ __ ] are
they only in the countryside because are
the city's dangerous would snake since
they just got bigger the snakes not so
much I mean I grew up in a country I
just grew up in a small small small
country town north of Melbourne and
Cleveland and I grew up with like snakes
all the time
spiders spiders are in my city house as
well so Oh God
every way I'd walk into my room and
they'd be like a spider on my bed I'm
like that another day did you notice how
long my god slider on my watch what see
what it's a [ __ ] cell phone on her
bed when she could spider you know what
we say spider right we go oh there was a
there was a spider this is how we say it
you go there was a spider
ha ha ha what the [ __ ] is that yes this
matter read you bedtime story yeah got a
[ __ ] spider cooking eggs a [ __ ] in
the mornings like what's a bug spiders
eat birds
that's awesome tight advisor should eat
birds oh dude every time you use a sound
limitation thing to like remove spiders
you know you don't want to Jones dude
dude watch me like spiders eat birds is
like me waking up to a farm here and
watching a cow in a pic or something
like shit's not supposed to happen
yeah or cow feeding a lion yeah what the
third of the third supposed to eat the
spider
how long is he a soldier a bath creature
this thing's pretty crazy I didn't the
first time I heard about sound in a
medical environment is back from day
when they remove kidney stones
it'd be really enviable and they would
they would have to like cut your kidneys
open and Polamalu but the now they have
technology where they know the frequency
that the kidney stones vibrate up so now
they can just vibrate it and then it
breaks up the kidney stones and it only
vibrates the kidney stones and now your
kidney can dissolve in the kidney you
just pee it out oh this would be a great
sex toy why because it's vibrating yeah
it could just take a dick in a vibrating
sound wave
yeah I could probably just do it with
your clothes on to just blue and then
you can use the machine to like move the
come get to come and then keep it
together and then make it go down your
neck throw it in the trash can or do you
come in the toilet it goes it goes out
of my pants right here how the [ __ ] is
your foot so glad I've been barefoot
this whole time always say I've never
seen it that perfect I walk outside
Black Sun I walk outside with barefoot
I'm training my feet to be strong resume
medicine knowledge in a way where you
can like levitate big objects like
giving yourself would you guys be down
that is important anybody will be down
for that in the ancient alien Airy like
really high up as long as I'm not
falling inward yeah yeah interesting I
trusted what I really want is a non
negative effect steroid I keep on
evasion that's what I want I want a 2-0
problem and just e to people get even
more it yep whoo that's what then
barbell will fail no you still got I'm
just gonna train all thinking like don't
even train it's just a pill and you can
do anything any also like a pill that
converts your taste buds that makes
everything that's helping this world
tastes like something amazing
that's unhealthy exactly like a carrot
tastes like [ __ ] baby back ribs who
was this kale salad to you but that's
just a [ __ ] pile of bacon to me yeah
I'm stupid I can't do that [ __ ] about
can do why can't you guys have been
useful things like that people like us
yeah but if you could make healthy foods
really taste good that means that
everybody would be more healthier so you
won't even need that are you stop making
adjustments that's like the chemist at
fast-food restaurants they get garbage
pieces and then they make it into the
best gourmet meal ever that's true the
filete oh fish is it even fish I don't
even know who gives a [ __ ] hey guys
would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos check it out appear
[Music]